yesterday we uh
we talked about cash you guys know gang
stocked cash
um
so today
i found another video of her she has a
book coming out and and by the way
uh a.g just to help you out here i i
found a royalty-free chiptunes version
of the twin peaks music so
in case this is clipped we should be
safe
anyway this is cash okay we all know
cash we did a little
we did a little whiteboard demonstration
with her yesterday
she's writing a new book she believes
she's being gang-stocked
so
let's check it out
hey guys it's cash and today i'm going
to talk about my second book
um my second book i know i told you guys
is just about this
whole um gang stalking ordeal
that i experienced everything that i
went through in miami
my usual suspects that i had you know
it was a lot of confusion for me because
i didn't understand
who was doing this for what you know i
was going through a very
she's not cuban i thought she was but
she's not a spiritual transformation
and to have this happening to me
on top of it it was just not it was
a very intense and not
a delightful experience so basically
the book just details
you know it fills in the blanks the
spaces between
um the first book you know the escaping
possession
so it gives you the the whole back story
on it and it's more about escaping
possession
her book is called escaping possession
business in a sense so the first suspect
i i know i talked about it in videos um
was my ex i thought it was him you know
and
like i couldn't get away from
that because in my targeting
that narrative so she's immediately
blaming her right her poor ex by the way
i don't even know the guy
but her poor ex she's immediately
blaming him
so this guy probably got a bunch of
messages that were like i know what was
you
you [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] what's wrong
with you you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'm gonna kill you but now she
realized it's not
now it's it's but remember it's not that
she's she's crazy
that whole thing was used against me the
most
and it didn't help that his baby mama
was
emailing me through my mom and my whole
time after i had
no contact notice notice notice
she's wrong she's you've already
admitted that she's wrong the way she
acted the things she did
she's wrong and
she's still doing the typical this isn't
the the gang stalking part this is the
typical like
crazy woman trick of still saying
that well it's you know even though it
wasn't him it's his baby mama's fault
for emailing me notice it's never her
even when she's wrong it's never her
fault
with him whatsoever so obviously like
that's where
i believed the targeting to be coming
from
and you know we went through everything
with restraining orders and things like
that
and then looking back now i realized
that
the restraining order probably was
a mock restraining order because they're
really i got dismissed
but they wanted that to be in place
so they can mess with me and get me into
legal trouble
she does kind of look like the scuffed
ray
from the new star wars what's ray
ray what ray street walker
i'm proud of myself for that one come on
i'm proud of myself for that
one ray street walker
because she's a hooker and that's me
being derogatory torture she's actually
a hooker
and because that's what the whole gang
stalking thing is about
is getting somebody into legal trouble
so
i look at the the way that they were
using him
and like the restraining order so they
were using him to get me to potentially
reach out to him and
like that was one thing and then you
know the karen setups
all the manufactured setups like that to
get me to act out against people of
different races and things like that
um and then my second suspect the person
who funded my business you can read the
book to find that out
um that with that whole situation
i just found a lot of parallels between
this specific individual and like
agencies escort agencies and stuff i i
don't know
if that is no for sure but
i i i was supposed to pay this person
back
and he just seemed to know
about the things that were happening to
me in miami as far as like the stalking
and stuff
so i just kind of sorry frozen just sent
me the book
i'm not gonna pay you to stalk me
because i think i'm actually doing
you a favor she's doing
them a favor
okay this is her book escaping
possession
okay i got it come on i gotta show you
guys
this is her book
escaping possession
after a painful childhood and
adolescence that shaped the person i
would become i did not take the path
most people take
when they get right uh school instead of
going to blah blah blah
blah whatever um
hold on i'm gonna get a better picture
of this give me a second
give me one second here
[Music]
all right here it is
oh my god
is this supposed to this isn't her i
mean this is her she wrote the book this
is her
but there's no way this is this is uh
this is her hold on a second
she's saying that this this is a this is
not her
k ash that's her writing name
oh my god
chapter ones up there oh
please please don't make me buy this
book please don't make me buy this book
[Music]
i'm gonna have to buy this book guys
[ __ ]
god damn it
so then you go to my cop friend um
this was somebody that i really trusted
this was somebody that knew
everything about me um we did have a
romantic relationship
for about i don't know two and a half
years a year and a half
i don't know so something like that but
it seemed like
everything that we did together was
things that relate to targeting like the
casinos
um the fake so
this is some reviews not chris and
ashley not chris and ashley i feel
cheated love it love it love it
i love that enjoyed her writing and
humor this is going to help people in
abusive relationships beware rock
chris rock chick christian ashley did
not write this
so there's further there's a rock trick
named christian ashley kristin ashley
so people thought it was hers our great
and sometimes failable christian ashley
did not write this she's
she never charges 99 for book no matter
how much we might be willing to pay for
them
the writing is also very far from her
style while this author may share the
same name
she should have at least included a
middle initial to differentiate our
christian
readers and plenty of discriminating
that stated that this is an important
subject the author needs to revise
her presentation and price do not buy
this uh this is not kristin ashley of
the rock
chick books do not purchase not rock
chicks christian ashley
this is not rochester's christian ashley
serious subject matter chris and ashley
ashley's rock chick was good for rock
chick anything after not so much
try and read the hook up lol this is a
good book from a person who's
experienced narcissist abuse for
viewpoint it's a serious subject
this is a true story not some cheesy
romance novel is she using her name
is she using her name to sell books
wait so so there's it
[Music]
hold on because i i got to see something
here because
there's a different chris and ashley
rock chick whatever the [ __ ] that is
let's see something here
[Music]
yeah so there's a christian ashley
that's uh is a new york times in usa
today best-selling author more than 75
books in 14 languages
she used her name
what the [ __ ] she was trying i think she
was trying to fool people
because the real kristen ashley
is a new york times and usa today
bestseller
she's using a well-known person's name
to sell book
[Music]
oh she is a scumbag stuff
so i just kinda i was like i'm not gonna
pay you
to stalk me because i think i'm actually
doing you a favor
so then you go to my cop friend um
this was something was it a cop guy that
goes to the strip club that you have sex
with
just curious somebody that i really
trusted this was somebody that knew
everything about me um we did have a
romantic relationship
[ __ ] called it [ __ ]
called it i [ __ ] called it
for about i don't know two and a half
years
a year and a half i don't know so
something like that but it seemed like
everything that we did together was
things that relate to targeting like the
casinos
um the facial recognition scanners he
took me to a gun range
you know to get a gun in my hand to get
me comfortable
with shooting um a
pistol or whatever and it just seemed
like everything that we did
was only geared towards targeting or
ritually abusive situations
then of course you have the other agents
in this industry they probably wanted me
out for obvious reasons you know the
prices i
wanted to keep the prices high they were
trying to lower them
maybe because you're not worth the
amount of money does any did you ever
think of that like
for the economy is pretty tough right
now so even hookers are going to suffer
a little bit
or escorts excuse me be politically
correct
sex workers whatever you want to call
yourself the men in that industry
i don't even know why they're there but
they had beef with me as well
then they tried to make me believe that
it was the mob
which i didn't believe because if the
mob has a problem with you they're just
going to
kill you there's no questions asked
they're not going to do well
she reads too many extra commands and
stuff
and as far as the jewish mafia there
really is no jewish mafia
give you a little history they had beef
with me as well
um then they tried to make me believe
that it was the mob
um which i didn't believe because if the
mob has a problem with you they're just
gonna
kill you there's no questions asked
they're not gonna do all these
you know extra games and stuff um
and as far as the jewish mafia goes
there really is no jewish mafia
meyer lansky was the last jewish
gangster
he was in cuba i'll give you a little
history lesson okay here we go
in cuba and they had the casinos and the
girls and the stuff
out there dropped and um
[Music]
castro ran them out and when castro ran
them out
they teamed up with the cia they wanted
to get castro out of there
so when they teamed up with the cia that
is when
the jewish mob became jewish
intelligence
so because they didn't want to get run
out of any other places anymore
so how'd that work out for them
oh yeah i mean i guess whatever you want
to call it jewish mo it's jewish
intelligence cia
and then they also have ties to
freemasonry oh police
are tied to freemasonry so you kind of
have this whole
umbrella of people that think that
they're like gangsters and
all this stuff and it's just their
intelligence they're civilian police
they're civilian spies
and if these people actually live the
life of a gangster or
knew what it was all about they probably
would not want to live that life
because it's not glamorous
and it actually does a lot of damage to
people
and their families um then of course
they wanted me to believe that it was
gangster rappers
after me so i would freak out and move
away
and pack up all my stuff um
there was a lot of social justice
undertones oh
okay like i didn't believe who's they
who are these they
it was gangster rappers but like
i i couldn't get away from the social
justice
narrative and that kind of playing into
it some way
you know i it crossed my mind you know
maybe i'm white they don't want me
having this type of business here in
miami
miami was getting you know
more urban in this time
miami is you mean south beach is urban
look
south beach urban and all that stuff
jewish people and white and white people
still own businesses in miami so
i don't know what [ __ ] fairytale
world you're living in lady
um and i openly never supported blm
and if you don't do that you were
considered
to be like a racist person now just
because i don't support
blm uh it doesn't mean i don't support
black people in their
fight for equality okay i
she's so stupid she may be one of the
stupidest people in the world
i do support that i i i think that
anybody that says
that there is not a problem with that
you know there's inequality amongst
genders men and women so
to say that there's not inequality
amongst races is just
wrong but i do not support blf
um and then the feds and then blm you
know
they were in charge of like some kind of
like gang stalking thing
and with the civilian police or whatever
that also crossed my mind
and then the feds you know because there
was
times where i would go out to eat and
stuff and
i could not have a meal without there
being some police presence so now didn't
you date a cop like i don't understand
like yesterday you said it was 37 and
then it was the feds and there was a
jewish intelligence agency there's a
jewish mafia then it's a regular mafia
it can't be everything oh my god she
looks like a [ __ ] a potato
across the street from me or something
like that or um
a what do you call it a now youtube in a
century the chat disconnected for a
second
routine stalker like somebody i saw all
the time somebody i was conditioned to
seeing all the time
they would have the person uh walk
around the block
to maybe elicit some type of reaction
out of me
you know to get me to act out like what
are you doing you know whatever
so if the feds are on you that's the
thing about the feds that's why i kind
of was like eh
it could be because they did you know
sabotage
all my relationships my
so the feds sabotaged her relationship
it was the feds that sabotaged her
relationship
it wasn't her poor choices and the
terrible things that she does
and the way that she probably panics on
people and blames him for everything
that's wrong in her life
it wasn't that it wasn't the fact that
she's a stripper and a hooker
it wasn't any of those things it was the
feds that sabotaged
all of her relationships all of her
relationships were sabotaged
because of the feds
because that's what they're doing they
have time to bother you
cash to bother you
wow she's a [ __ ] idiot
um investors i guess you can say
my benefactors however you want to put
it
like it pretty much sabotaged all those
relationships for me and that is
something that the feds do
so if the feds are on you
if you're not doing anything wrong i
mean it really doesn't matter
but it's stressful it's very stressful
and
they go out of their way to
tell you that they are watching you
um but so i came down to the conclusion
like this is police presence i came to
the conclusion that i came down to the
conclusion
this is federal agents or
the police you know i didn't obviously
think it was my friend
from chicago at first but if you're a
cop you can have
you know correspondence and just call up
miami beach police anytime you want
so that's all i have to miami beach
police speaking of jewish intelligence
to say about that her channel name is
kristin
ashley my second book
is just detailing all this craziness
that i went through
and kristen ashley's not even a real
name by the way i really do believe that
she used this
to try to sell books i really believe
that
because
why else would you do this
hmm
i want okay i'm gonna read a little bit
of chapter one what do you say guys huh
it should not have been a surprise to me
that i ended up in this situation like i
did
for years i was for lack of a better
phrase an emotional punching bag for my
father's cruel
psychological abusive behavior my father
wasn't a bad man
but he had a dark side that was
amplified by his alcoholism
there were two sides to my father the
happy-go-lucky prankster that would find
humor in any situation in the passive
aggressive drunk
who seemed to thoroughly enjoy tearing
my mother and sisters and i down so the
guy just seemed like a normal dude
doesn't seem like it was abusive
but it gets everybody else's fault
growing up weekends
were the best because it meant we would
have the happy jokester that sat and
watched the weather channel and cnn for
hours and told the same stories about
his upbringing
over and over again laughing like it was
the first time he told us
weekends were peaceful we lived for the
weekends in my home growing up
my mother would work until mid-afternoon
leaving my dad in charge
we would sit and watch movies or sports
i grew up
loving sports because it was the only
thing that brought me close to my dad
i would watch hockey with him i knew the
whole chicago
blackhawks roster by heart i would sit
there and watch games with him on
games with him and cheer on saturday
morning when i was about seven years old
we were sitting watching movies and my
dad was doodling on a notepad
cash come here he said chuckling i went
over to him
he tore off a piece of notebook paper
wet the back of the paper and stuck it
to my forehead what are you doing
i asked laughing you'll see it's a
tattoo he said
i waited and he removed the paper from
my forehead i rushed to go back to look
in the mirror
i had no idea what the symbol was but
but my dad did
so it must have been cool my father was
laughing what is this i said giggling
he said saying any he didn't say
anything i couldn't wait
to go show my neighbor friends down the
street my new tattoo i waited until my
dad took his unusual afternoon nap
and snuck outside to see my friends i
played all the way up until i saw my
mother pulled up to the house
my mom's home i gotta go i shattered to
my friends and spread it towards my mom
she hugged me and looked at my forehead
cash what is that on your forehead she
asked
oh dad gave me a cool tattoo i said
what the get in the house she yelled at
me startled and not knowing what the
problem was i walked towards the house i
can't believe
you would let her go out of the house
like this she yelled my father
she yelled to my father she hurried me
into the kitchen started scrubbing my
forehead and wiping
away what was left of the swastika
my dad put on as a joke
it's kind of a funny joke
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh no
oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
her dad put a swastika
on her as a joke
hold on a second
[Music]
let me see something here
[Music]
probably
okay as a matter of fact
i believe
i believe i have a photo of it hold on a
second
here it is this is what this is what you
look like guys
this is a true story this is something
that really happened okay
i don't want any of you guys laughing at
her all right this is something that
really happened to her
okay see that are you happy now
it's not so funny anymore is it
it's not so funny anymore is it
[Music]
oh we're all having a good time until
you're a kid with a swastika on your
head
[Music]
unbelievable
wow
her dad's a [ __ ] monster can you
believe that
[ __ ] gross dude that's [ __ ]
disgusting
jesus man i apologize you guys had to
see that i really do
i don't know it was going to be it was
going to be as dark as it was you know
i know her father was going to be that
kind of person that would do those
things
you know so
anyway let me continue here again
i didn't mean that i didn't mean for you
guys to have to see that okay
uh let's see here just
this is gross you know
and yeah so i hope that everybody has a
wonderful day and as always god bless
uh we'll continue after the swastika
thing
it was a joke uh i didn't tell her to go
outside this is after the swastika thing
back to her book i didn't tell her to go
outside he said most likely she's just
waking up from his nap
what the hell is wrong with you shield
back at him the neighbors are going to
think we're
all you could hear was a childlike
laughter coming from the bedroom i
[ __ ] love her dad
uh that was my father on the weekend he
was not
far from it for some reason he would he
found things like that to be extremely
humorous he had a dark offensive sense
of humor which probably explains
where mine came from during the school
and work week we experienced a different
side of my father he would come home
around
5 or 6 p.m sometimes 10 p.m intoxicated
if he had
if he had made it into the house and
didn't pass out on the lawn
we were treated to unfiltered onslaught
of verbal abuse
most of it was directed at my mother but
often my sisters and i would fall victim
as well
i need a son i wish i had sons
i recall him saying once after my
sisters and i ran into the bedroom
with my mother after he upset her i had
no idea
then how these words would stick with me
and mold me into such an aggressive
female but they did
i love my father on the weekends but the
energy draining incubus he became during
the work week
made me despise him i loved my mother
very much but around that age 10 i began
to view her as weak
i hated the way she enabled my father
and that [ __ ]
uh that fueled my dislike towards him
even more until the weekend of course
this consent love-hate relationship with
him paved the way for several more
roller coaster relationships throughout
my adolescence as well as to my
adulthood my upbringing was stable in
terms of having home but unstable
because we didn't know
if we were going to be forced to leave
or go to my grandma's house to get away
from my father's alcohol-induced rages
my mother would always threaten that we
were leaving for the last time but
always
eventually ended up back where we were
we repeated the same cycle again
and again i hated being home so i spent
a lot of time at my friend's house my
mom would tell me
i had to come home and i wouldn't my mom
released from all the chaos at home was
sports
i played basketball volleyball softball
all the way up until my junior year of
high school
i especially liked the long distance
tournaments because it meant no one
would come watch me play
and i could just focus on the game when
i was in seventh grade
i was a starter my basketball team the
other four starters had their dads as
coaches for the team
i was the only starter whose dad was not
a coach okay that's that's
first off it's weird to have that many
coaches on a team
instead my father would come to my games
drunk and yell instructions from the
stands
people probably could not tell he had
been drinking
but i could i usually did not play very
well when he would show up like that
years later at my younger sister's
volleyball match he showed up
drunk and i saw him walk out of the
woman's bathroom
at the school we were we were watching
her
uh because he said he couldn't find the
men's
i insistently became upset and i
screamed at him you're not going to
embarrass
her like you embarrass me i yelled in
front of a group of the opposing team's
parents
i'm sure they thought i was nuts but all
the memories i had of him
shouting commands and acting foolish
came back to me and i couldn't help but
lash out
i should have realized then that my past
with my father was a huge trigger for me
and sometimes uh and something that i
needed to deal with but i chose to
ignore it
and let it fester inside of me burning a
hole in my soul for years to come now
i can't read anymore because this just
has a um
a preview of it but who knows maybe i'll
buy it
maybe i'll buy it and we'll keep reading
it and then everybody clapped yes
correct and then everybody clapped
uh man she is
she's something else i i'm sorry that it
took so long for me to go back to her
it's been a while
man i'm reading some of the titles some
of these videos where i don't know if
we're going to go through all of them
today but
voyeurism in china research firm and
drug profiles
cardi b and only fans and why it's a
problem
uh fugazi street theater parties oh my
god
let's see the cardi b one i'm sorry i
was gonna move on but just real quick
hey guys
it's cash and i am here today because oh
she's dressed she's a hooker drive
she's got the makeup and she's all
hooker dressed up now
she's she's dressed like like she's at
work
hey guys it's cash and i am here today
because i came across something that i
think
needs to be talked about so the thing
that i came across
is celebrities with only fans 15 stars
who have an account um
okay there the reason i need to talk
about this
is because this is
probably one of the reasons why we we
are where we are as a society
as a culture um i feel like the internet
has made you know of course
us more accessible to celebrities but
it's also made the celebrities more
accessible
to us and things that we do
and i think that it's kind of blurred
i don't understand like thank you rm i
don't understand
[Music]
um
either one video she's dressed like a
[ __ ] potato in the other video
she's dressed like what is what style
she going for here
the line a little bit between
regular person and celebrity because now
we're seeing all these so-called
celebrities
on this only fans you know taking money
from people that are in the adult
entertainment industry
i want to charge you know bigger
fees for subscriptions on this only fans
if you don't know what only fans is
from my understanding of it it's geared
more towards adult entertainment
you know um like the porn there's no way
you don't have an only fans
industry and stuff you can find somebody
you like you subscribe to them you get
to see their content
well now you have these celebrities on
here these influencers
and they're charging 9.99 for
subscriptions
and that's probably what an entertainer
or somebody that's
actually showing nudity should be
charging
so not only does it look desperate
but it's putting these so-called
celebrities
in with everybody else
in with are you upset
because other people are doing the thing
that you do
you're a stripper slash escort
and also being gank stock as well a lot
you're a lot of things
you're a jack of you're a jacket many
offs if you will
but now you're mad that other people are
doing it you don't want anyone [ __ ]
getting in on your game
with normal people and as someone coming
from the stripping industry
this is not something that i want to see
okay i don't want to see
cardi b who supposedly was a stripper
on only fans for 9.99 and hold on i'll
read it to you guys
okay okay so in august cardi b became
one of the first a-list celebrities to
join only fans
the 27 year old rapper however did
warren fans right off the bat not
to expect any x-rated content that's
what this site is
for so you're charging 9.99
and there's people out there that have
to charge less now
that are showing this content so you're
just because because look and
i think it's all stupid because people
would rather
people would rather see naked famous
people or
rather see lewd famous people the nude
nobodies
i'm not saying i agree with the
ecosystem
but that's how it works right
i'm just driving the market down is
basically what
cardi b is doing so and to be clear
no i'm not going to be showing my
titties or my [ __ ] or my ass okay
that's pretty much the point of it cardi
b like you're just missing the point
totally
totally okay oh and here here her her
page originally launched with a 9.99
monthly subscription which she then had
lowered
to make her page more affordable okay
so honestly looking at this i don't
think cardi b
ever really lived her stripper life
i have seen pictures of cardi no no no
no no no no no no look i i don't i don't
like cardi b
but cardi b absolutely was a stripper
i mean she's admitted to drugging people
and [ __ ] them from strip clubs
so cardi b was a stripper
b what she looked like you know when she
was a stripper you know
and i don't think she ever fulfilled
that stripper fantasy that
that actual stripper life because
anybody that has been in this industry
anybody that has you know quote unquote
been
that [ __ ] has been able to run amok in
a strip club and
you know make this and that they're not
looking back when they supposedly have
all this success
okay if i'm cardi b and i have all this
success
the last thing that i am doing is
getting on all these fans
and she can say oh it's easy money it's
this and that you're taking money away
from people right now during a pandemic
oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] off
man
everybody has an only fans now
that's [ __ ] life but you're mad
because she's taking
money away from your industry
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you something cash
you and cardi b are not competing with
each other
you got you guys are not competing with
each other
for several reasons
[Music]
and you're not even posting nudity
you're not even doing it like
it's one of two things it's what i said
she never really lived her stripper life
or two she's not as successful as she
claims to be she's actually
no secretary has plenty of money but
it's just free money it's the same
reason you [ __ ] a bunch of actors are
doing youtube now
it's easy money probably struggling and
you know this is not something that's
uncommon
tlc number one song
grammy award-winning artist they were
broke at the grammys
you know so this this to me
it's just you're cheapening the market
these celebrities they need to like
this is this is what happens when you
make
people with no talent famous okay
this is the type of stuff that happens
because they can't do anything else they
can't write
they can't you know if i'm cardi b i
can't write either we just read some of
your book
i'm writing my own songs i'm in the
studio i'm making music i'm doing
things like that you know i'm taking
acting classes because she didn't do a
bad job in hustlers i'm taking acting
classes to get
bigger better roles i'm not signing up
for only fans
this is a disgrace okay so
and then it gets worse didn't you fly to
iowa for a [ __ ] strip club interview
okay so aaron carter joined only fans
over the summer
where he's allegedly posting some pretty
racy photos
users can subscribe to the 32 year old
singer page for 27
a month okay cardi like you're getting
beat out by
aaron carter here like no disrespect was
aaron carter showing butthole back to
aaron carter i had a huge crush on
aaron carter back in the day but
you know i don't know whatever you got
to do to get through life
so this is what i think needs to happen
and this i'm being
completely 100 percent honest
um as someone are you normally not
gone through this industry and done all
the things that
you can do in this industry and
what the pinnacle is considered you know
i've reached it
i'm going to tell you guys what i think
that cardi should do okay whether she
listens or not it seems like she's
already doing it
she needs to take a year she needs to
work in a strip club
so cardi b who was a stripper
who is now a megastar i don't like car i
[ __ ]
i hate cardi b but who is a mega star
needs to listen to cash's advice who
thinks she's being stalked by the
federal government and jewish
intelligence
and go back to a strip club
are you guys listen are you i want to
make sure i'm getting this correct
am i am i so far getting this correct
that's what she's looking for right she
needs to go in my free cams
only fans she needs to work on that um
put herself in the position to be cyber
stalked
okay because that's what you're doing by
putting yourself on the internet and i
will post my videos
about that down below and she also needs
to do some bachelor parties organize
some events do something why
get out of here why would cardi b need
to do any of these things gosh
because it's very apparent to me that
she has not done any of that
because anybody that has done things
like that is not
back pedaling okay so strippers anybody
entertainers anybody with a brain in
their head is watching
cardi b right now backpedal like this
and they're like
okay bloody shoes [ __ ] like what are
you doing
you know it just it makes no sense and
that's why
we have a problem in society today
with people not being authentic
okay this is very inauthentic you have
somebody
that you know she raps about this stuff
and all this stuff she's backpedaling
in her career she is literally going
backwards okay so that's all i have to
say about that
i don't have only fans i should be on
only fans but i refuse to get in only
fans only because i know
the internet the internet somebody's
subscribing to you and they're having
viewing parties
and probably charging people to come in
and view in their room and view your
content
nobody is having viewing parties
for you you [ __ ] rando
the way viewing parties are you serious
do you think dudes are calling
every other dudes to come over to jerk
off together but i understand like oh
viewing parties for a pay-per-view like
i understand viewing parties for like a
ufc
or [ __ ] wrestlemania or [ __ ] you
or [ __ ] mike tyson or a [ __ ]
boxing match
or a super ball but nobody's having
viewing parties for only fans while
people
jerking off together what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you literal lunatic
[Music]
like the internet is just not the place
to be
busting it down so that's all i have to
say about
that so if you want to switch places
cardi
let's go by all means everybody have
a wonderful day and as always
god bless
she she is just a barrel of fun honestly
this woman is a barrel of fun